excuse me there's a sign at ramit Park
that says do not drink the sprinkler
water so I made sun tea with it and now
I have an infection
sir sir are are are are you listening to
me sir sir I'm talking to you sir sir
are you aware that there is waste in
your water system parks and
R confirming what
that's not
possible oh
no hey good morning why are there six
people outside who say they're waiting
to meet with me so you know how you love
me because you haven't had a single
meeting with anyone since I became your
assistant that's because every time
someone calls and requests a meeting
with you I always schedule it for March
31st why because I didn't think March
31st existed 30 days has September April
March and November June and
November today is March 31st I know so
then how many meetings do I have today
93 okay what's your idea to go in that
room and finish this book oh really yeah
is it good yeah you're going to stay
here and you're going to help Donna do I
look like I drink water I've started
interviewing people to fill in for
Lesley I have found five candidates I'd
like to hire and two I'd like to be LIF
luuck friends with well you will not be
hiring anyone because my department is
just finishing up a major
project
everything excuse me everything I'm
wearing is suede everything I'm wearing
is suede everything excuse me everybody
attention
I think you'll agree that this
department could use a little leadership
kamazi Ron can I have a burger I'm
hungry for the last time no Burgers yet
I've got ribs and I've got beef cheek
Ron where are my vegan soy patties oh I
gave them to the kids they love them
they're skipping them across the pond
Donna I got to go to the boy's room can
I have a ride in your car absolutely not
this barbecue stinks I'm saying it it
stinks do you have any plates or
anything I mean how are we supposed to
eat these rumps Ron if no one takes me
to the bathroom I'm just going to have
to go in the trees all
right forget it you have ruined a
perfectly good barbecue with your
demands and
chatter enjoy the rest of your
evening excuse me we have an issue a
tweet has been tweeted from the parks
and wreck Twitter and I'm afraid it is
quite sexually graphic it's probably
just some Bor teenager who hacked the
account whoever it is is quite serious
take a look at this I don't want to get
recalled no but damn these people know
how to pick a neck massager and before
you get on my case about those stickers
I already did them Donna there is
trouble of Brewing we think that you may
have accidentally tweeted from the parks
and wreck account rather than your own
personal account uhoh what did it say
see you tonight hope you like tongue
baths you big nasty firemen then there's
a picture of a pair of lips and then a
picture of an eggplant I'm both confused
and if we're being totally honest a
little aroused you not to give you too
much of a peak into my personal life but
this could have been way
worse hello Leslie how long have you
been sleeping with
Ben what how long have you been sleeping
with Ben that's disgusting and wrong I I
don't even get why would I I've never
had sex with anyone anywhere it's none
of your you have the nerve the audacity
Ben is my boss technically and he is
terrible face wise and how how do I know
frankly that you're not sleeping with
him maybe you are maybe you're trying to
throw me off H check and
mate this is an outrage who do I call
hey hey he Hey Hey Hey Ron listen you're
just who I was looking for are you did
you forget the um did you can can I get
that thing can we just uh did you bring
it this isn't convincing I need to find
someone to fill in for April now I know
I'm not going to find someone who's both
aggressively mean and
apathetic April really is the whole
package but I think I might know someone
who will be just as
ineffective that a
hello Andrew what's new um a whole lot
check this out I just invented it super
straw so just sit here and do your thing
do I have to tuck my shirt in because
honestly that's kind of a deal breaker
Let Her Fly April could you come in here
a
second April way to come in great
initiative you called me in listen could
you please call an per
and tell her that I will be unable to
enjoy lunch with her today as I am just
swamped all day copy
that hi an this is April I'm just
calling to let you know that Chris can't
make lunch
today I knew you wouldn't care
goodbye Ron Swanson it is my pleasure to
inform you that you are a finalist for
the job of assistant city manager Chris
I feel I should remind you that I do not
believe that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me I will walk
deeper into the belly of the Beast if it
means I'm able to further limit Reckless
government spending I mean I have so
many ideas some are simple like take
down traffic lights and eliminate the
post office the bigger ones will be
tougher like bring all of this crumbling
to the ground committees are power and
committees make things happen committees
are the lifeblood of our democratic
system that's really really good write
that down yeah from time to time when I
think of an eloquent saying or a phrase
I have Tom write it down he's collected
them from my Memoirs here's Leslie's
quote from
Wednesday okay read it back to me
um committees cover our democracy with
blood
H sounded better when I said
it still good
though I'm going in why don't worry I
have a heart hat on thought I could see
that but yeah April document this docent
what the key to any fact finding mission
is to get right into the Battle Zone you
know it's like George Bush when he flew
over New Orleans or Richard Nixon when
he went to China to see what the Chinese
were up to
no Leslie are you
okay Leslie hold on April's going to get
some photos for the website can you just
be still don't move around as much well
one of the funner things that we do here
in Pony is the annual Easter egg hunt
Tom hides the eggs and I have to say he
did an exceptional job this year I've
been searching for 25 minutes and I
haven't found a single egg and I'm an
adult oh yeah I forgot to do that maybe
Tom's trying to make this year a
challenge and if so he's he's succeeding
I don't think a single egg has been
found yet let's keep looking we're going
to find
one